Germany and the Netherlands have proposed
the world's biggest mega project
that would protect Europe from the rising sea levels.
These two massive dams
linking Norway with Scotland and England with France
would have a total length of 637 km
and would completely enclose the North Sea.
The scientists believe that the sea levels
will increase between 84 centimeters and 2 meters
until 21. This would mean that a lot of coastal areas
from Germany,
Denmark in United Kingdom
would be affected.
But the most affected country would be the Netherlands,
which already have a third of its territory
located below sea level.
The North European enclosure dam
would practically disconnect the Baltic Sea
and the North Sea from the Atlantic Ocean.
The biggest challenge in realizing this mega project
would not be the length or the money needed,
but the part of the dam crossing the Norwegian trench,
which have depths of 321 meters.
So do you think it's possible?